nothing it was that the girl papi you
try to tell me you're a college graduate
yes he got I have an MA and Ivan PhD I
also have four years of high school and
that case dr. Reagan gonna read your
nomination thank you daddy
it is easy for me to introduce regularly
family
to put it quite simply he is a
consummate professional over a long and
distinguished career Gregg has brought
an insight and sensitivity to a
tremendous range of characters and made
every one of them believable and that is
the true test of an actor he's an Oscar
winner and former president of this
Academy ladies and gentlemen Gregory
Peck
but it's a long trip from Brooklyn to
Buckingham Palace and it's a far piece
from Beverly Hills to an obscure village
in Bangladesh Danny Kaye has made both
journeys sustained by his remarkable
gifts his grace and his intelligence
he's been a star of the first magnitude
since his remarkable talent exploded on
the Broadway stage in lady in the dark
in 1941 and one who's had a high sense
of priorities his wife Sylvia and
daughter Dina have always come first in
his life and then in no special order
his work the world children and great
music for UNICEF United Nations
International Children's emergency fund
he continues to travel the world
bringing joy and hope to children on all
the continents initiating programs to
save them from hunger and give them a
better chance in life he's been doing
this for years with no pay and without
fanfare no trumpets no headlines his
reward the laughter of children as
forbearing and skillful as he is with
children so he is with symphony
orchestras groups of 70 or 80 highly
disciplined artists he cannot read music
yet he has conducted major orchestras
all over the world with musicianship
that is sensitive completely serious and
at times likely to veer off alarmingly
into the hilarious Danny's irrepressible
joie de vivre make his concerts joyous
occasions for musicians and audiences
alike Bach and Mozart have no better
friend nor have the orchestra's and
their pension funds nor have we and thus
for his prodigious Labor's for the
children of the world and the wondrous
people who make music the Board of
Governors proudly gives the Jean
Hersholt Humanitarian Award
to a citizen of the world who does honor
to our profession mr. Danny Kaye
I was a young man comparatively when I
came here tonight I am really terribly
excited to be given this great honor and
I'm so delighted that I find myself as
we say trembling if I want him more
delighted I think I'd be in an
institution
however I I feel a little bit guilty
about all the praise that Greg lavished
on me it was really no hardship at all
really
I am crazy of our children I'm crazy
about conducting and I am crazy about
flying I am definitely not crazy about
disease or famine or neglect but then
neither are any of you and we all of us
in our profession share a long and
wonderful tradition of doing something
about it of giving of our time and our
talent wherever and whenever it's needed
without prejudice without sting that's
one of the reasons that I am so very
very proud of our profession and so
proud to be one of you I share this
award with you
with all of you and I give thanks to the
memory of DAG hammarskjöld and maurice
pate with whom i started to work for
UNICEF about 28 years ago
and to G Normandy who put a baton in my
hand my little nervous hand and made me
an offer I couldn't refuse to stand in
front of a Symphony Orchestra and
conduct
hooah that's the greatest feeling of
neurotic power in the world you ought to
try that my very special thanks to the
Board of Governors I love this and I
love you thank
present the Award for Best Supporting
Actor here is the man who wanted for his
superb performance in cabaret and a star
who keeps winning our admiration for a
variety of performances that provoke our
laughter move us to tears and win our
devotion Joel gray and Carol Burnett
you